hey guys I'm going to be promoting my
new podcast the way back here for the
next few weeks I'm very excited it's
going to drop every Thursday beginning
January 4th right here on my YouTube
channel you don't need to subscribe
anywhere else we'll work on getting it
out there wherever you get Podcast it
will be available but you can watch
video for sure right here on YouTube yes
I'm continuing the Honeydew it's just in
addition to that something fun something
a little different um going back to my
Ro in podcasting a little bit so I'm
excited for it um it's called the way
back and it's just a Nostalgia podcast
sitting back on that that uh station
wagon back seat the one that looked out
in traffic you know that's the one the
best seat in the house talking about
growing up and you know just laughing
and having some good times you're going
to get the way back on patreon also a
day early you're going to get it ad free
as well um I'm really excited for this
show I really M it got a great response
when we dropped that first teaser and uh
our first guest to kick off is Tom
sagora so it's going to be a great one
we've got a bunch of them in the can
already um you're going to see Mark
Norman Jim Gaffigan Joe list they're all
on there all right uh so make sure
you're already subscribed and uh here's
a little taste for
you I remember growing up we were
terrible kid my brother was a bit of a
pyro take GI Joe's we would tape bottle
rockets we did the mailbox baseball
we're shooting BB guns Roman Candle
fights my mom didn't like anybody she
didn't even like her own kids these are
wire neighborhoods I didn't have a
curfew or a house how's all you bro a
dog chasing us was a drag queen M noan
Ryan that fast ball boom right my
brother's
face yeah those were the
[Music]
days
the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
[Applause]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pant Studios I am Ryan sickler
Ryan sickler docomond sickler on all
your social media I want to W wish each
and every one of you a happy New Year uh
I hope 2020 24 is way better than 2023
for all of us um just want to say again
please go check out my special Lefty son
I'm proud of it put it out there support
it I want to get to a million views on
it we're over
800,000 that's blowing my mind uh the
patreon guys you saw the episode with
Josh Wolf if you haven't go watch it go
watch it and then go subscribe to the
patreon it is the wildest show on
patreon it's the best bang for your buck
I promise you the stories you guys share
are way more interesting than anything
you're going to see on on TV and very
excited to announce the way back drops
this Thursday it's my new podcast we sit
on that old station wagon back seat and
we just reflect on the old days um my
first guest is Tom sagora that'll be
dropping this Thursday all right and we
are going to launch that episode at 6:00
p.m. Eastern 300 p.m. Pacific I will be
live in the YouTube comments if you want
to jump in there join me please
subscribe it you you guys know what to
do rate it review it all the stuff that
helps pods get out there and grow and
and get up the charts so people share it
and see it please there's a separate
audio feed for it as well so if you're
one of those people that just likes to
listen man go over and subscribe
everything thing is at
ransler um you can get all the info
there uh dates the live and Al live tour
is going to be back on the road I wanted
to take January pretty much off and just
rest my back get a little bit healthier
but we're kicking it off in February
going to add a bunch of dates so go to
Ryan sickler
docomo over here we're highlighting the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers I'm very
excited to kick off
2024 with this guest first time here on
the Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome HF welcome to the Honeydew buddy
I got this dude I love the mugs love the
mug class class W I've been trying to
get us to do it for like a year just so
you could do the Sip you know what I
mean yeah but you know what else makes
me laugh that that's what we think is
[Laughter]
classic usually drinking out of a cereal
tell I'll be honest with you back in the
feast days we had mugs but they would
break a lot auor shipping we were like
what do people use that's lightweight
and won't break and we were like Koozies
bro Koozies you should do you have are
you garbage we have about 12 cases of a
thousand koozies that we that we bought
and we're supposed to sell or bring on
the road you want but you want mugs love
them the mug on the on the set that's
old school Johnny yeah that's class
that's class put a little Jin in it um
so before we get started today please
plug promote everything anything that
you would like yeah are you garbage we
do uh two public episodes a week on
YouTube and anywhere you get your pods
uh we also have a real fun patreon where
we put a lot into a lot of behind the
scenes stuff going through each other's
houses stuff on the road yeah I like
seeing you guys out there set those
[__] bars like look man if we hit
this level we're this is what's going to
happen and I like that you're put I like
that you're not just taking from the
people that you're putting back into it
and getting out there and engaging with
DP but everything we have into it great
idiots but yeah they took me to Disney
World cuz I never been for the first
time that's a that's a childhood trauma
all my other cousins going to Disney
World and I'm sitting home like a
[__] fing [__] I hated Disney
World for the longest time 47 so the
first time you went was just like 40 47
first man sometimes it takes a while to
close a wound you know when I saw that
Magic Kingdom I
was trying to get goofy to give me a hug
tell me everything was going to be
okay and we're on tour we're on tour
right now we're doing the state trashy
tour standup comedy plus we play a
little aru garbage with the crowd at the
end uh real fun time um yeah here in La
we did the region theater unbelievable
yeah man good for you guys thanks buddy
it's been fun seeing it's been long
overdue I know the god last time it was
[__] over a year or so ago we were out
here yeah and I couldn't get you at time
no it's all good man um it all happens
for a reason it does right yeah like
Disney World bro it comes around so I
want to talk about that because it was
meant that I couldn't fit on Magic
Kingdom or whatever it was Space
Mountain space m dude I was hanging out
of that thing like I was on a side car
did you get on everything uh we only did
uh we did the the roller coaster at the
Safari Kingdom uhhuh and then we did
space uh Space Mountain and then the
other ones were the Star Wars ones where
you
know they're plan they're planed for
larger client I mean if you can't fit in
the Millennium Falcon you got you got
big problem listen man if you're bigger
than shaca get the [__] out of here all
right space can't hold your ass you
wouldn't fit on the Death Star what the
[__] yeah but the um it started sinking
like man that thing and sucked into the
gravitational field Space Mountain I was
hanging out of it hanging out of it dude
were you really wild whips and [__] like
that D I thought for sure that I was
going to [__] get taken out by
something some animatronic arm just
[__] slic my throat but my knees were
popped out like I was sitting like this
like a cartoon brutal but it was fun as
[__] my favorite ride there still one of
them is Peter Pan did you get on any of
the kid ones no Peter Pan's the [__] bro
we got my it got ruined cuz it's so
funny that of course it happens like
this but my mother and I didn't speak
for 25 almost like 30 years we reconnect
after my daughter she comes out wants to
take her to Disneyland so we all go to
Disneyland and I asked my my buddy who's
from high school whose daughter he he
happens to live out here in t I'm like
will you just come and go with us and
just buffer a little bit be a buffer be
nice to cuz he'll talk I don't have to
you know carry the conversation and we
get on the Peter Pan ride and it's just
like a little cart and if track in the
air and you fly and you're seeing
everything Never Land down here [__] we
go take this [__] turn dude and all
of a sudden and then we're just sitting
there and they're like please stay in
your seats we have a technical
difficulty like oh [__] man I don't were
you sitting next to your mom my daughter
was in the middle
always and they turn the [__] lights
on and they ruin it you see the guys are
down there [__] they're down there
working they can't help it the whole
lights are on our buddy what' you get
into last night ah this [__] broad
was how you doing kid good to see you
sorry about that sorry about that sir
just need some more pixie D down here
kids my buddy and his daughter are just
like it's a turn around they're just on
the other side of this wall uhhuh and
I'm like Jimmy he's like we're right
here I'm like God damn I can't even see
him you know what I mean so now I'm
hanging we're in there for like 20
minutes and I haven't talked to this
lady and we're just hanging
uncomfortably in the Peter Pan ride with
the lights on finally they get us going
and then they let us all get right back
on and then go back through again I was
like you son of a [__] man I would have
never done that again yeah fool me once
get jammed up up there so tell me where
are you from or originally I was born in
uh Upstate Pennsylvania in a in a city
called wilsy okay wilberry Scranton I me
family in scand yeah so the two the two
cities next to each other I was born up
there and until I was in about uh second
grade we lived up in uh place called
Mountaintop so this is I was born in 76
so we're talking uh this is right as the
80s are starting to turn my dad uh was
in the Navy he was in Vietnam and then
got into the Navy drove truck for a
little bit and my mom just did like um
you know she worked at like the gap or
something so he was able to you know
support everybody and we're talking like
something that step Spielberg would
would lay out for a set like it was a
new development it was all new families
it was real quiet it was real you know
borderline country and it was [__]
awesome big wheels driving driving big
wheels in the middle of the street I
remember sitting in the street just
smelling the asphalt like in the middle
of the summer just like picking at tar
like a little fat kid in the middle of
the street never thought of a car
driving by or running me over or
anything so it was awesome babysitters
cousins live next door right next door
okay so you got extended family all
right great do you have brothers and
sisters I do I have one older brother
he's 18 months older than me oh wow so
we're kind of Irish twins yeah so you
have pretty much somebody growing up
that was your age right in the house to
oh yeah to [__] battle with every
single day day yeah 100% yeah it was
wild but we did that then we moved into
wilbury for a little bit um what did
your um parents do for a living my dad
was in a Navy my dad was a was a
recruiter a reserve recruiter for 26
years and he did that all through was
his success rate what was his Bat and
average oh he did doing Top Gun came out
he didn't even need to do anything
[__] printing money you kiding me
that's when you all move to the new
development yeah dude I didn't even
realize it until the one came out last
year when when when the new one came out
last year it like clicked in my head and
I remember I was like Dad was that like
did that make it easy for you like ah we
were [__] printing money you kidding
me all you had to do was walk in with
those sunglasses on and they'd be lining
up yeah it was [__] it was uh he he
would travel a lot though he would go
from like wilberry to like uh New York
and Philly and blah blah blah so he was
he was he was away most of the week and
so he wasn't just one of these guys you
see at the shopping mall back in the day
that recruiter sits there and you got to
walk in you know what I mean no no no he
he's actually out there recruiting they
were hustling yeah and um then he got
stationed in kind of a um a stationary
spot in Willow Grove Pennsylvania uh
where he kind of finished up uh uh his
career there um so if he's doing
traveling a little bit for work what's
mom doing she just home taking care of
everything [__] deal with us yeah
she's dealing with us and we were
outwardly everybody thought we were the
sweetest kids cuz they were you know my
parents were [__] awesome and they
were you know you be polite you be
respectful you don't cause trouble you
don't do this and a lot of that was
anxiety driven on their part and like so
like if we went to now if I go to a
restaurant I have such social anxiety
about not knocking anything over not
being a problem not spilling anything is
the card going to go through you know
what I mean do we have enough money this
that don't get that one soda blah blah
blah
and internally though we were [__]
maniacs I mean we we caught my
oh the three of us in that house on a
Wednesday night in the winter with
[__] uh [__] why is it got to be
the winter specifically I always just
feel like it was the
winter dude it was freezing outside
she's ripping heaters in there screaming
at us I wouldn't do my homework my
brother was like real your mom would
smoke in the house oh everybody was your
dad smoked to no everybody crushing I
remember being in the back of a Jeep
Wagoner in like 1981 one in a car seat
that had like a bungee cord like just
straight plastic like I I knew then this
thing is not that was more than most
parents care
though dude this is not going to save me
and driving through the snow and both my
parents in the front with the windows up
and the heat blasting just crushing
heaters and even as a little kid I was
like this can't be good for me but uh
yeah we were we were up there for a
while and then we moved uh my mom's side
of the family was from down outside of
Philadelphia in like this really awesome
suburban area that every time we'd go
down to visit I'd be like [__] like I
thought they were everybody was rich you
know so then we moved down there and it
was uh it was awesome and it was it was
always awesome and I had a I had a good
childhood which is uh crazy why I'm so
[__] up you know what I mean there was
a lot of like the anxiety and the social
anxiety and the you know the dysfunction
inside the family but I mean my parents
did everything for us they [__] were
so loving and so awesome so supportive
about sports or anything you want to do
um they were just [__] they were cool
[__] they were crazy uh they were they
affectionate were they lovey-dovey were
they or were they just like did they
seem more professional I can tell you
this and my parents split early but I
can I only remember seeing my parents
hug once okay never hold hands okay
never kiss they were hot and
they were hot and cold they were they
were
very uh I don't want to say passionate
but they were I mean we were all [__]
nuts so you know my mom would start in
with something and you know he he would
be tired and they get into an argument
or we' cause a fight that's what a lot
of it was a lot of their fights were
because of us a lot of their fights were
because of me let's be honest I would
cause [__] trouble and then it would
Ripple through the household and then me
and my brother are fighting and then
they would get into a fight and then
that that would last um Sundays were
always like a big fight day I don't know
Sunday Sunday Fight Night always always
and I was just he's finally home from
the road your mom's had enough of these
[__] for the week it's your
goddamn turn [__] about it I mean no
they were always like a good nucleus but
like we were uh for as like hardworking
as we became we were very lazy when it
came to like you know make cleaning our
like me especially cleaning my room
raking the leaves I mean listen I I hear
that about but what kid isn't no kid I
know what kid do you know is like I
can't wait to get out there and rake the
leaves you're like [__] these leaves but
but what it teaches you in the end is
hard work it's hustle it's do your
chores it's you know create a structure
all that [__] is responsibility but I
was evil about it Ryan I was evil about
I'd fake heart attacks [__] walking
at I just got
perod swear to God how old are you
having a heart attack dude I would do
anything so that would be that would be
the start of it all right and we'd
always we'd always do great family stuff
like Sunday with my dad would make a big
breakfast we'd go to we go to church
come back big breakfast yeah you got to
have you got to fight on a full stomach
you know what I mean Sunday got watch
the Stooges together and then it would
just slowly devolve to the rest of the
day all right you guys got to go out and
Rite the leaves we cause a fight about
that then they would get no fight about
that and then they'd be yelling back and
forth then my dad starts cooking dinner
he's back there C te back God Dam
burning himself this that the other
thing he was a great cook they were just
they're high were high strung and then
we would the the fight would blow up it
would get resolved and then the
affection and the snuggles and the I
love yous and all that kind of stuff
would always it was always like that
there always had to always got to that
point always got to that point not all
[__] you guys were out of here no yeah I
mean my Dad pulled out a couple of times
where I was like oh he ain't coming back
Really and I was like honestly standing
there looking at the porch is like I
don't blame the [__] come I
would have been [__] gone gone with
what we you know what I mean and that
but that's all in the house outwardly
you know oh the boys are so good and you
know they're doing good in sports and
you know your brother so smart and all
that kind of stuff but it was [__]
chaos inside first time you remember
like your dad leaving where you think
like legit he might not come back
Christmas
1982 whatever year Christmas
this is again this is me Christmas this
is me whatever year liono Richie All
Night Long came
out uh I think that was the album the
one that had hello on it yeah with the
blind chick and all such and the fit so
whatever year that came out because my
dad had gotten my mom that album for
Christmas and Christmas morning you know
again lot of lot of stress you know you
you got your pajamas the night before
the new pajamas so when you come down
the steps we'll take the pictures you
unwrap everything are you still
believing in s at this point how old are
you oh yeah yeah I'm locked in I was
petrified too yeah so that caused me a
lot of anxiety I didn't like um I was
always really scared at night as was a
scared kid used to sleep with my brother
all the time but uh Easter and Christmas
as much as I love Santa Claus loved
everything about Christmas the thought
of a [__] dude who may or may not
have Supernatural powers coming into my
house in the middle of the night I would
lay there and look at the crack in my
door where the hall light was on in the
dark and I would just imagine seeing
this
[__] this old man [__] peek in
with a [__] straggly beard I [__]
hated it hate and the Easter Bunny dude
with the [__] teeth that would rip
you to shreds I don't care how much
[__] re you're bringing no no kids
see this is the way I look at some of
this [__] like Santa is real that's
that's what I tell my daughter but I'm
like that Easter Bunny's [__] some
of them you got to sacrifice you know
what I mean they can't all be realu is
real Santa's real that [__]
Easter Bunny's [__] she said to me
one time she's like you been the CVS
before you seen the candy know where
it's coming from three she goes dad does
the Easter bunny drive a car I go no she
goes man that's a lot of DUI a couple
years ago he did he got arrested on the
side of the
road [__] the Easter bu but no it was uh
it was Christmas it was the Christmas
that album came out and um and my they
spoiled us they didn't have a lot of
money every a lot of things were you
know my mother was a genius at juggling
credit cards and credit card payments
and [__] power bill payments and
everything it was a [__] house of
cards that would just you know never
fell and they would always do a really
good job to try try to give us great
Christmases whatever we want it and [__]
like that but I don't know for for some
reason that Year my brother got this one
[__] airplane that I just kept
playing with and I wouldn't stop and
wouldn't stop and eventually we got know
a [__] thing about RC plane or was it
no it was just like a do you remember
the GI Joe uh uh F14 it was like that
but it wasn't it was just like a
knockoff like a Fisher Price Jet Fighter
and I just [__] just wouldn't stop
and then we got into a fight then my
mom's yelling and then my you know then
I hear them yelling well why didn't you
get him this and and then that started a
huge [__] fight and then I don't know
sometime in the afternoon my dad just
[__] came down got in the car and
dipped might have just went to the store
or something like that but to me he was
gone for [__] four hours and my mom
just laid in the living room listening
to
hello over and over again and I remember
[__] being like man I just broke up
my [__] family you know and
eventually he came rolling back in he
always came back he always came back
does that song you feel a certain way
when you hear that song to anytime today
no I like it it's all right yeah it's a
catchy dude shout out to Lio Richie
little all night long never hurt
anybody good stuff dude I [__] I've
been working on this story on stage but
I um this is kind of you mentioned lonel
Richie so years ago many many many years
ago um getting out of this relationship
but it was one of those relationships
that I've been into many times where
things just got bad and you're you know
you need to go but you haven't done it
yet you're staying you're trying to and
like you're getting out of there and I
finally that's my whole life ended this
relationship cuz now I have that thing
from my parents you don't leave you
don't leave yeah yeah if they have your
back you don't leave so she didn't so
I'm getting out and but it was also it
wasn't ugly in the sense that
like it was it was one of those like I'm
I'm free I'm glad I'm not devastated I'm
this is long overdue good for you you're
finally stepping up and that is the best
feeling you think it's going to be I'm
going to miss her and then all of a
sudden there's that one Saturday where
there's a crisp in the air and you don't
no one's breaking your balls you have
everything in front of you you don't
have to fall in love again to get again
the whole nine yards and that Saturday
that you're talking about my friend hits
me up and she's coming in from New York
and she's like hey and she's been
talking to me about this the whole thing
and I'm like did it finally done she's
like I happen to be coming in um I'm
going to bring the company card we're
getting sushi at Koy on Lasana going to
meet me there and I'm like you got it
and back at the time I had my 1990 Honda
Civic with original rims and I lived in
in thereal original
rims and I drive my Civic up and over
the canyon and down into Hollywood and
the whole time I'm listening to liono
Richie and the commodor
um sale on okay best breakup so it's not
a sad song He's like look man shit's not
working out I'm giving you back your
name is you know good for you get the
[__] out of here right yeah nobody did
break up songs like no especially like
Donald Rich oh forget and I'm singing
this thing at the top of my lungs over
and over all the way to the restaurant
we get to the restaurant we have great
meal and at the end of dinner she's like
I'm going to pay the bill and I'll meet
you out at valet I said I'm going to use
the restroom I go in the restroom take a
leak I'm washing my hands I go to grab a
paper towel and as I turn around the
[__] door opens up and H Foley in
walks lying on [__] Richie I
swear to God and I say on stage like I
was as surprised as he was when I said R
Richie like I [__] myself okay cuz he
and then right away I sort of like I was
like I'm sorry I don't mean to cost you
in a men she ripped my heart out man I
loved her I H but I told him I go look
man I'm I know you're about to use the
restroom but I just the reason I react
that way is cuz I was singing Sal on the
whole way over I just got out of this
relationship I'm feeling good about
myself I feel and he he was so goddamn
nice he oh I love hearing that man
that's great that's great oh chats me up
for a minute about it then I leave he
does whatever the [__] he does I'm out
front and uh I'm waiting with her at
valet and then he walks out and I've
been say I don't know why he said it
like this but when he walked he saw me
took her back huh he's he's
like that quick that didn't last long he
said good to see you
Ryan like but like he know me forever
you know what I and I honest to God I
didn't know what to do and I just hit
him with all right lion one of those and
he just sailed on into the night bro all
right
now aw your mom's crying the
hello a dude it was brutal so good dude
yeah I thought you were going to go
another Direction with that cuz I
remember when I first moved in I thought
she was going to be there or something
like that you were going to walk out and
all the confidence and all the
excitement was going
to no man Lionel Richie [__] walked
in that bathroom I still I was like get
the [__] out of here yeah cuz I had a
break up uh in New York deserved 100% um
but it [__] devastated me and I
stayed in for like you know like a
couple months I like wouldn't go out
wouldn't do anything all that stuff
trying to get her back calling her all
that kind of stuff [__] nothing um
and it finally got to a point where like
her mom talked to my mom like listen
it's over and blah blah blah and all
that stuff so finally my buddy's like
dude you got to get back out there you
got to not like get back out there but
you got to get the [__] out of your
apartment um and he's like come on we're
going to go to dinner I'm like dude I
don't want to go I don't want to this is
in New York I'm like I don't want to go
to dinner I don't want to see her what
the [__] is wrong with you it's a
[__] City 9 million people you're not
going to [__] see her so we go out
and it's like me him and a couple of his
friends and we're like at like a long
table and like I didn't really know
anybody so I was just [__] sitting
there like a dork [__] sure as [__] I
look up no and [__] looking in the
like at like where the you know the menu
is is [__] her and some guy a and I
just [__] hear in my head
hello just [__]
devastated devastated and I'm like
[__] look and he turns around he's
like oh [__] that
sucks and I like walked out there to see
her but she was gone and no lion o
Richie out there I'll tell you that Ryan
I could have used them you could where
the [__] are the commodor I would have
took a pip
somebody her's [__] Barry White when
you need him big man don't worry about
her oh man that's brutal dude yeah I had
a couple of those where I [__] up the
relationship really bad couple of those
same dude yeah I don't know anybody that
hasn't though there's there's people out
there that [__] up relationships
believe me we all [__] them up some
people I I I mean I don't mean it but CU
we were that for someone but some people
are like practice people what do you
mean like like you don't it's a pra you
don't mean to you think it might be
forever but it ends up just being
practiced for the next thing and sure
like we were pra I was I'm sure I know I
was some sort of practice person for
somebody else had that like [__] you
know Blue Collar Bruce Springsteen like
we're in it together I love you baby no
matter what we're riding down Thunder
Road together and that always led to
[__] cuz it's the wrong sure the
wrong solution yeah but that's I learned
that you know what I mean that back in
the day you know not that I would you
know I wouldn't take anything I wouldn't
I mean you you know would you change
anything I don't know I'd always want to
be a Foley though I can tell you that
cuz they're a [__] they're a fun
group of psychos same dude I say all the
time if anybody if I could come back
back as anybody else I would genuinely
come back as myself again i't as much or
the Next Generation like come back as
your grandkid or something yeah but back
in this family these people 100% for
sure and I know that's just because
that's how we were you know that's all
we know but I swear to God I really
believe that like I would always want
I'd always want to come back a Foley
yeah you know what I mean it's been fun
it's been ugly but it's been fun yeah
100% um well speaking of ugly uh we were
talking before the show and I and you
mentioned that you lost a a best friend
yeah and it was your first best friend
first best friend and I was like how old
were you and what' you say
kindergarten that's early we were Nom
together Ryan [__] thick and Steves
of this kid
ear yeah that's that kind of [__] set
the tone of what do you remember about
that like you he was your buddy in the
neighborhood and at school that that mid
Mountaintop [__] red maple a um you
know just [__] like a a late 70s
early
80s [__] postcard all right and every
day [__] see him and [__] you know
pictures me and him and just we were
just boys you know what I mean I was
obviously tight with my brother and
everybody but my brother had like you
know since he was older he had his best
friend and I had my best friend and my
cousin had his best friend and all stuff
and we were just over each other's house
all the time over at his grandmother's
all the time just like those endless
[__] days of Summer even that young
they seemed like Millennium you know
what I
mean uh and then [__] one day I go to
his house and I knock on the door uh and
I think I remember these beats like
specifically and I knock on his door and
his mom just comes out and he's like oh
no Robbie he can't come out and play
today [__] whatever I don't know and I
remember walking down the the front
steps like the little sidewalk hopping
on my [__] big wheel and [__] just
pedaling on
and was that the first time that you got
like a he can't come out the first time
I got the he can't I'm in Kinder I
couldn't comprehend in a billion years
you I figured he got pinched for
something or something like
that got jammed up in there and I did
that my mom told me this uh the extent
of this uh a couple years later that I
did that for I did that every day for
like two months I just kept going to his
house but the mom always just kept
saying he can't come out come out today
can't come out today and after 2 months
she called my mom and said hey you can't
have my mom knew you know once something
like that happens in a small
neighborhood everybody knows hey
Robbie's he had can he had cancer it's
also every parent's worst
nightmare dying you know they're dying
thinking about what everybody else yeah
my fat ass is showing up [__] every
day Robin you got my Transformers you
[__] I think I know you took my star
scream my brother needs that Fisher
Price Jet back Robbie your mom can't
hold me out for long I know where the
extra key is Robbie I'm telling you
right
now so did that for for a couple months
two months that's but also just I feel
like as an adult I would I would have
called your mom way before way before
two months way before probably one time
hey this fat little struggling with this
[__] right you think you can have your
kids fat little bastard out of here
Jesus Christ I don't got any Twinkies
kid get out of here so you've probably
heard of micro doing if not just know
that all sorts of people are micro doing
to feel healthier and perform better now
look I've tried everything for sleep I
even went recently to go check on sleep
apnea all right you name it I have tried
it and these micro do gummies work you
guys know I'm a big smoker but I'm
telling you when it comes to sleep I I I
have a high tolerance I got to take a
couple of these gummies and an hour
before I want to sleep boom I take them
and by the time I in bed I feel just
good and relaxed without all that mental
background noise or back pain that keeps
me up all right micro do gummies deliver
perfect entrylevel doses of THC that
help you feel just the right amount of
good to learn more about micro doing THC
go to micro do.com and use code honeydew
to get free shipping and 30% off your
first order again that is micro do . Cod
honeydew micro do.com Cod honeydew for
30% off the farmer dog was founded by
two dog lovers who decided to reimagine
pet food from the ground up in the five
years since they delivered their first
meal the response has been incredible
the farmer dog makes and delivers fresh
healthy dog food it's developed by vets
nutritionally balanced and made from
real healthy ingredients to human food
safety standard it's the best option for
dogs at all life stages because it's not
k hibble it's not canned goo it's just
real healthy food not only that it's
also pre-portioned specifically for your
dog based on their unique nutritional
needs this makes it easy to help your
dog maintain their ideal weight which is
one of the biggest indicators of a full
healthy life it doesn't matter if your
dog is young or old it's always the
right time to begin investing in their
health helping you live more healthy
happy and full years together get 50%
off your first box of fresh healthy food
at thefarmersdog.com SL honeydo plus you
get free shipping just go to
thefarmersdog.com
honeydew to get 50% off she's tearing it
up that's
thefarmersdog.com
honeydo if I asked you how many
subscriptions you have would you be able
to seriously list all them and how much
you're paying if you would have asked me
this question before I started using
rocket money I would have said yeah but
let me tell you I would have been so
wrong I can't believe how many I had and
all the money I was wasting going to
cancel these old old subscriptions used
to be a long phone battle with customer
service but luckily rocket money has
even made that easier rocket money is a
personal finance app that finds and
cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps lower
your bills I can see all my
subscriptions in one place and if I see
something I don't want I can cancel it
with a tap I never have to get on the
phone with customer service they'll even
try to get you a refund for the last
couple of months of wasted money and
negotiate to lower your bills for you
buy up to 20% all you have to do is take
a picture of your bill and Rocket money
takes care of the rest rocket money has
over 5 million users and has helped save
its members an average of $720 a year
with over 500 million in canceled
subscriptions stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions by going to
Rocket money.com honeydo that's rocket
money.com honeydo rocket
money.com honeydo now let's get back to
the D so then like a few months later we
moved and that was like uh a very not
tumultuous time but like my cousins had
moved a couple like months earlier so
that whole existence left and that was
you know a very close relative of my mom
and they had three kids and you know we
were just like a little [__] Squad
they moved and then shortly after that
we moved into closer to wilbury and just
being a little kid I just kind of not
forgot about him but just you know
things were just moving and then I
remember um I think like that might have
been in the fall or something like that
and this would have been in the summer I
think um we were just driving one day
just me and my mom we're driving by his
place where my dad play softball and uh
they had just gone to a funeral like two
weeks before and when we moved closer to
wberry we had all my older cousins I had
I had four of the coolest guy older
cousins that we looked up to and [__]
loved and they would always babysit us
whenever my mom did something or
whatever they would just come in throw a
huge raging party they were all in high
school they'd roll in a keg of beer and
it would just be [__] chaos make me
and my brother fight in a pit like it
was the [__] dude it was the best so
anytime that happened I didn't care what
it was I knew you know [__] cousin
duck or cousin Flo was going to show up
with a [__] Squad and a couple
cheerleaders for I candy for the big man
so I was [__] cool with it and like I
remember I was so excited that he got
there and like we walked up to like
Turkey Hill like this this uh like food
market we got like candy and [__] like
that and it was like the best time ever
and can I just for like walking to the
store when you were a kid buddy just
that buddy and getting baseball cards or
candy or acks on you ice cream yeah and
then you're going back home like [__]
yeah man yeah that's a that was such a
good time as a kid just that dumb [__]
walk to the store yeah it was it was
[__] it was the best [__] goofing
around you got a stick in your hand
you're hitting [__] nothing going on sun
going down just [__] yeah like a like
a valentine wild but then a week later I
was driving with my mom and I was like
uh just out of nowhere it just popped in
my house like Mom when can we go up to
Mountain Top and see Robbie again and
[__] heer gets [__]
the heater gets smooshed out in the
ashtray in the car midig and when that
happened you knew it was something
serious and it was aund dud I
got I got something to lay on you the
radio gets turned down F dude short of
just pulling over to the side of the
road and give me one of
these so she's like do you remember the
funeral we went to a week ago and I'm
like yeah of course [__] cousin Joe
came best day of my life what are you
talking about man [__] yeah [__]
got Gob Stoppers and [__] laughy Taff
do I remember it what are you talking
about I think that was the I think that
was the first time I saw the the bubble
gum in the in the milk cartons remember
the little like Fruity bubble gum I just
told my daughter about the milk hard and
the do you remember the hamburger and
the actualy it was actual styrofoam dude
and I was telling her my brother blew a
bubble one time so big and it popped and
it sucked back over his face and he had
to get his head shav to get all the
[__] gum out I gum my hair a couple
of times lot of peanut butter [__]
getting cled in there listen she just
said that she goes you know peanut
butter gets scum out of here I go no
well we didn't know that where the [__]
were you we're buzzing at all like that
we peanut butter heavy plus we got life
it worked yeah it worked yeah no [__]
and we I was just thinking we got lice
twice which was weird for a kid we got
lice two times me and my brother you
know we got mites which is kind of the
same thing we got it from playing indoor
soccer and they they never Chang the the
turf you know so you're going down on
this Turf where mites yeah mites it's
like a body sickler boys got termites
God damn it so yeah you ready we're the
dermatologist and it's my turn to come
in and see the dermatologist and my
dad's already sitting there because it
was my brother that got it and my dad
goes bad news we got M and I say the
house what are you talking about I could
have swore I scratching up there and in
front of the dermatologist he goes why
do you have to be an [__] I said what
are you talking about he's like it's not
termite we're the dermatologist right
now we're not at the [__] leak in the
bathroom too I didn't want to [__]
idiot I was like that's when I learned
what M were I'm like we basically got
body crabs is that what the [__] you're
saying no more sleepovers for a few
weeks everything's getting washed and
burned man dude lice yeah never got that
but got the the mites yeah light lice
twice once ruined uh Fourth of July
driving home getting yelled at I don't
know why cuz we had lice [__]
fireworks going off in the distance and
we're up in the bathroom and she's got
that lice comb
[__] like she's husking corn [__]
just ripping scalp out but she [__]
hit me and she's like uh and she you
know my mom do you remember how she said
it um just you remember just straight up
just [__] hit me with it and my I'm
super close with my mother super close
super close with my dad and they're
[__] they're you know the best like
literally the best and you know they've
always been very with all the rough
edges and the fighting and the
dysfunction super loving like I could go
back there now I could go to my mom's
house now and live there for the rest of
my life if I want it you know what I
mean cutlets laundry the whole nine
yards which some would say is a was a
detriment why I'm such a [__] [__]
but either way the Cuties are hot you
know what I
mean yes I do they're cool as [__] like
that but um yeah she was just like you
know that funeral we went to I remember
exactly do you remember that funeral she
went we went to a week week ago that was
Robbie's he passed away and that was it
and then [__] a heater came out the
radio went back up we were coming
from got song
up yeah [__] liono getting me three
times son of a [__] we go back to the
house and uh I remember I just went up
into my room and I had this picture of
me and him like something out of Back to
the Future you know the Back to the
Future picture with the brother and the
sister Lally I got a Philly shirt on I
got a [__] jean jacket pair of jeans
he's got a [__] like Penn State
sweatshirt on and it's just [__] me
and him like [__] buddies in a
foxhole just [__] smiling and hugging
and I [__] stared at that thing for
[__] man what felt like days and just
that's when it started to all uh that's
when you know I realized I nobody had
died up until then except people that
had passed before I could remember like
my mom's mom had passed away um but up
until that I was I was somewhat clean
and her dad passed away when she was uh
when she was young which that kind of
leaked in into us you know that trauma
leaked into us a little bit but this was
the first [__] hit and it was a
[__] kid you know what I mean so
that's when I realized like oh [__] you
know I'm going to die we're all going to
die and death always became a [__]
you know like it is with everybody just
[__] just brutal and then a few
months later I think uh my grandfather
died or maybe my grandfather might might
have passed a few months before so that
was like a you know a double hit was
that your mom's dad it was my dad's it
was it was remember seeing him no I got
the I [__] answered the phone though
he died of they were super close and
[__] you you asked me before why why
do I go by H Foley and not Henry um so
when I was a little kid I had this like
wooden plaque hang H over my crib and
over my like my first little bed that
said H period Foley in Wood it was one
of those wood shop Johns that one of my
cousins had made for my grandfather uh
because I'm I'm named after him he's
Henry William Foley I'm Henry William
Foley so when you know he pass and all
that stuff I you know that was my
inheritance whatever that's your Heir
wood shop other people get [__] life
insurance Wills that's what I got
hypertension Factor five light and a
soap box car nothing El you got a you
got an heirloom wooden piece yeah uh
which is hangs in my nephew's room now
cuz he he's he's an H um but uh I
couldn't read it or understand it you
know what I mean because it was in like
that dark wood and it wasn't they didn't
do a great job to be honest with you
they weren't the best in wood shop so it
was it would just looked like a like a
like a dark piece of wood and then when
I finally figured out that oh H Foley H
Foley that's for you know what I mean as
a little kid so I always told myself
that that's that's what I would use you
know kind of in honor of him plus I like
the way it sounds but my dad was super
close with him man is your dad in h
Foley as well no he he was Terry okay
teren Michael um but they were super
close and this was around the the Robbie
time like I can't really remember but I
remember my dad took his death really
really hard because we we had this bar
downstairs that he had made and we were
having like a again like a Christmas
party or something like that and I was
sitting on the bar like on the bar
facing in and you know he was always a
[__] rock you never saw any emotion
other than don't do that what are you
doing you know whatever or you know a
little bit of paranoia but you never saw
crying or anything like that and he just
he he just was sitting there standing
there and like you know there's a full
party going on he had his head in
between my lap and I'm like Daddy what's
the matter and he just said I miss pop
[__] rip your heart out [__]
brutal so yeah best friend grandfather
bang bang There you go
yeah I um my grandmother was our mom
basically and she was I remember you
telling us that yeah she died and I
remember a moment at my younger
brother's wedding my twin brother is not
like nothing he's zero motion zero he'll
call me and say something like you
should have seen your niece at this
dance recital today almost cried he'll
you know what I mean like he'll never
let himself it ain't happen but those
are the guys that when they do when they
go yeah everybody's it's like that one
viral video where the guy's
like he just [__] lets out 40 years
dud when those cuz I've been in
situations where like I did see my dad
actually cry you did oh man it was uh
tell me about the first time you
remember seeing your dad cry I remember
that this going to be another real hum
Dinger and I apologize I apologize to
everybody this is what this story is I
mean this show is dude tune in to the
crying fat guy show everybody let me
[__] fill my
water uh we had a we had a situation in
our family uh where uh one of our
cousins uh had a new baby
SIDS right away I've done benefits for
that and that was a
[__] shock wve through the family and
that was the first time I ever saw my
dad and I think I was probably maybe 11
or 12 at the time maybe 13 and yeah
never seeing like him or my uncles or
like anybody like that ever [__] like
break down and man they were [__] you
know grown men they realized the gravity
of the situation and it [__] shook
the [__] out of them and [__] like I
saying when that when they start crying
everybody's [__] crying yeah yeah
[__] brutal it's it's I don't know
it's something about a man crying makes
me cry more you know when I'm see a dude
crying I'm like oh it's some [__]
crying man yeah yeah especially when you
like respect them and you know they
don't cry yeah ooo but I remember but
then they throw on Field of Dreams
they're all [__] B yeah let's
go I uh at my brother's wedding so this
they have this you know video on and my
grandmother pops up and my brother looks
at me and he's like I miss grandom and I
mean this is like that's the mo and I
was and I see him tear up and stuff and
I was like me too dude and I just let
myself cry and I'm like he's over there
all watered
up I'm like did you just sneeze or are
you feeling something deep here right
now you know what I mean like it's
[__] man statue ass yeah so I
want to talk to you a little bit about
this because you said your father just
passed and you've just started talking
about it yeah he passed in uh September
of last year so a year ago year ago sick
for a little while um from what he got
uh so he was in Vietnam and uh he got uh
Parkinson's and uh something called
Louis body's disease what's that one
it's like a form of dementia and um it's
one of the diseases that if you were in
Vietnam during that time when they used
agent orange which he was he was [__]
in the thick of it that was something
that could happen so they fig and we
have no history of any of that in our
family or anything like anything like
that um so he got [__] he got that
[__] from from from agent orange [__]
slowly snuck up on him so how old was he
when um
things started affecting his body that
way I would say probably 68 if I'm right
or wrong I could I could be wrong here
but I'm pretty sure he was 72 when he
died um and I think it was about a three
or four year situation you know the hand
started going a little bit and then what
got him was the was the Louis bodies it
just [__] it it just shuts your
bodies down it's I'm don't quote me on
this but it's something about some kind
of protein in your brain that attaches
itself to something and it slowly just
[__] you know stops everything from
working um but uh yeah so that was I
would say that really started to hit
before the pandemic
maybe uh sometime in
2019 he you know it's he he didn't tell
anybody with about it for a while um he
just started seeing [__] all right now
when we were kids from the war every
once in a while if my mom wasn't home
he would turn off all the lights in the
house no oh yeah he would turn off all
the lights in the house we and I'm
talking the funnest [__] guy we're
playing Guns we're running around we're
[__] you know making popcorn we're
[__] hanging out we're playing Atari
together all that stuff and every once
in a while [__] all the lights in the
house the flood lights would go up and
he'd make me and my brother sit in the
little picture window and look just look
out for how long just for like you know
an hour whatever you know what I mean
till he felt like everything was cool
was he right there with you yeah he
would sit there with us damn I'm
thinking
this no I'd be out smoking a joint out
back like these [__] are on
Lookout out
here I think what I think what we we
think
Patrol he's out there looking he's got
the galinsky kid jacked up against a
[__] wall you [__] VC H you son of
a [__] [__] playing Russ I'm
je I deliver your newspaper take it
easy
I got your gr you have two kids who are
fine I your wife's lying on Richie CD
don't you
remember now what a he was so he was
stationed on a on a PBR base the little
boats and when he first got there in
1971 there was like 1,500 American
soldiers on his base the [__] like
the Army was across the Delta all that
stuff the last few months that he was
there it was him and 15 guys they had
pulled out they had you know whatever
moved the thing and it was them training
the South Vietnamese how to use all this
stuff and the the fear of being they
were 40 Mi south of the demilitarized
zone and the fear I think the main
things they weren't like in the [__] but
getting overrun every night I think was
a thing and I think that translated into
that kind of behavior where like
sometimes he would just wake up in the
middle of the night turn all the flood
lights on and just [__] look out and
we'd come down or if the dog started
barking out there or something like that
so he would he he would do [__] like
that so there was there was a little bit
of that in it and the way I kind of
uh analyze it or deal with it I feel
like the symptoms you get from that [__]
is stuff that is things that were rooted
in you your whole life like if you're an
anxious person or whatever cuz you
started singing like real [__] up [__]
so was it always War related or was it
just everywhere no no no so so the the
way we kind of all found out about it
was uh at work he was he he was he he
sold insurance after retire after he
retired from the Navy work with two guys
real great guys they were real tight
small little All State
office um all of a sudden he would just
be looking out the window and he be like
you see those people in those cars and
he did that a couple of times to where
the boys were like n something's going
on here and then one day he like
wouldn't let it go he's like there's
people in those cars you don't see those
people in those cars there's people in
those cars and then he called my mom and
my mom was like what the [__] so it
turns
out like a year before that my dad said
he was sitting there one night you know
cuz he doesn't say anything or want to
go to the doctor or anything like that
it's fine everything's fine he's like I
was looking out the window and I saw
like this like big pop of light like big
flashes of light or something like that
and you know you should have done
something about it not that it would
have helped him but you know you let it
go or whatever or just you know kind of
ignored it and then when that happened
then they they went went and they you
know saw the neurologist and the VA and
all this stuff and you know months of of
a process till they figured out it was
Parkinson's and Louis bod then he
started getting the shakes and [__] like
that and then uh right before the
pandemic he was just a little slow you
know what I mean a little you know a
little a little groggy a little slow not
as sharp and that's why as [__] up as
it is the time that I got because when
the pandemic hit uh I stayed in New York
for March and April you you know what I
mean just cuz that was when it was like
super super [__] tight and then June
or May June July we went down to my
parents and it was
literally our own little world the
happiest I've ever
been just being able to you know
literally just everything that I've ever
wanted right there being just them two
[__] being able to spend time with
him you know going for walks with him
going you know just re also at that
point he could still get around and
stuff he could still get around a little
bit yeah there was starting to be some
you know help him up help him this you
know things were starting to get into
that phase into that zone where last
summer that zone hit really hard he was
going to physical therapy and I think in
February of uh 2022 of last year he just
came out of uh physical therapy and he
just fell and they couldn't get him up
he just couldn't his legs just that was
it the brain wasn't saying no more no
more it was done
so they took him home they got him they
got him in bed and stuff like that and
then the next morning like like my
brother and my cousin had to come and
you know help him up and all that stuff
and then the next morning the same thing
happened again and that was uh the start
of [__] just the [__] worst of the
worst is that wheelchair bound now that
was that was hospital that was Hospice
Care in our in our in our in our this
first floor of our house oh man but was
that was his den that was his fireplace
that's his [__] TV [__] his I'd
rather be there than some Hospital buddy
and that's why I said before if they got
your back you don't leave and [__]
Patty fley showed that I mean she always
did but she had his [__] back cuz you
know he had Hospice Care he had hospice
nurses all that stuff but she was
[__] Round the Clock everything you
can imagine of that situation she
did 100% And you know I was home a lot
my brother was over there a lot and it
was just this you know just this year
period of uh you know just Round the
Clock [__] taking care of him which
you know if he knew what was going on
because at a certain point you know he
started to whatever it just got just
slowly got worse and worse and worse and
worse and worse he wouldn't have wanted
it he wouldn't you know just [__]
kill me that's probably what he would
have [__] said um and there were a
lot of times where you know like me and
my brother would just not discuss that
but but like he would would [__] hate
this he would hate that some lady's
[__] changing his diaper and that
[__] you know [__] Peggy from down
the street is standing at the foot of
his bed like oh you're a little trooper
[__] out of here you know all that stuff
would have hated it
but obviously the alternative wasn't
[__] you know realistic we're not
[__] we're not in L you know what I
mean [__] just kill me man yeah so you
know that was uh it's [__] up but it
was like a real uh
this s it was like a real beautiful time
that's nice we never had patience as
Foley never impatient fighting B back
and forth that over a very very long
period of time eventually kind of in
that moment taught us patients to be
patient to not get frustrated with them
and not get frustrated with my mom which
we did you know what I mean and her not
to get frustrated with us and this and
that so it was uh it was it was a real
[__] up weird thing and then um we uh
we were on tour at the time and he was
they were all they're always my whole
life
job Sports career [__] what that
comes first they would never want us to
miss anything because no no no you go
you go you made an OB you go so we had
this we had this leg of the tour in um
uh I want to say where's Springfield
Missouri Illinois yeah Missouri and it
was looking pretty dicey you know what I
mean we they were getting close you know
it's crazy the hospice nurses I don't
know if you ever dealt with them they
know they [__] know they could tell
by the way the toenails look like oh
he's starting to go yeah wild um but it
was we we had like a 4-day run coming up
and it was like he probably ain't going
to be here wait for you if you leave and
every go you got to go that's your
[__] you know the thing that you know
and they my my dad got to see us I
wanted to ask they ever get to see you
perform oh yeah he got he got to come to
the to to the last show we did in uh in
Philly you know we you know sold out a
comedy club that you know wouldn't pass
us [__] 10 years before we [__]
sold it out our fans are [__] the
absolute [__] best they got to see us
yeah he got to see us build the show and
you know all those [__] years that he
saw me struggle and [__] all this
stuff he got to you know he got to see
it happen and and [__] like that and you
know he was a huge fan of the show and
[__] Kippy and [__] this and that
it was Kippy do and all that stuff
because that's what he would when he was
home you know they'd watch they you know
of course they'd watch they they'd watch
areu garage sit there and watch break
balls this guy that guy I like that kid
out Christ Stephano he funny guy but it
was like uh they were like go just you
know you got to go you know you [__]
made an obligation [__] people are
counting on you [__] you go so we
went went and um he passed when we were
in uh when I was in Springfield uh in
the morning um who called you uh lion
Richie which is
[__] listen it sounds crazy
Master masterful my mom was banging him
the whole time no my brother my brother
was in there uh he was there with him he
was there and we had we we had a [__]
we had a run for a little while um of
situations in our extended family where
it hits like that like yeah we're like
you know my my uncle was like one of the
first ones that like [__] just
devastated me my Uncle Mike [__] like
just devastated same thing you know in
the it might be tonight it might be
tomorrow we don't know so everybody was
kind of skilled in that and you know the
the pride you know gathers closer and
closer as it gets to it and I think the
day before my brother was like you know
it's probably it's going to be could be
an hour it could be tomorrow and then it
was it was the next morning called me in
the hotel uh woke me
up you know said he was gone did the
show I think that night um got up the
next day flew to Philly and uh you know
did did the thing were you able to have
any like conversations with your dad
about that stuff before we always we
always did though or did he not want to
talk about death at that time and stuff
what do you mean just as that what
during the time he was sick and you went
back and you were able to be with him
did you have conversations about death
and uh things like that or was he like
no I don't talk about that sh no he does
we I mean we he always had a great
attitude about it you know what I mean I
think you know the experience he had in
Vietnam was what he had always told us
was uh getting out of that everything
was gravy on top of that so he always
had Hey listen he always listen when
your time's up your time's up he said
that a billion times didn't worry about
anything like that you know what I mean
if something happened like you know we
went to the doctor and they found a spot
or something like that you know he
stopped you know quit that he quit
smoking cuz you know they found
something on his lung or or whatever so
he was always he was never like scared
of any of that stuff and he always had a
good attitude about it but we always had
such good there never had to be that
final I love you I'm sorry for every
that happened all the time you know what
I mean and me being you know younger uh
the younger one I was I mean I always
you know I you I squeeze his cheeks I
get so chubby and you know I mean I was
always very affectionate with them to
the point where he get off me he quit
screwing around hey get over here I love
you you know what I mean so we always
had that so there was never any of that
and there's never there's not I you know
Believe It or Not don't have um much
guilt as far as not being there because
I know that he would want me to be where
the [__] I was supposed to
be and that you know that was uh that's
with the [__] boys doing doing are
you garbage living your dream yeah yeah
yeah he would they were all about that
all about that I um you know having a
daughter now to I don't care if she's
eight or nine or 10 go I play go play go
[__] play yeah don't be here today
and around this [__] go play I AG I
agree yeah they always well you may you
know if you're a good parent I would
have been [__] pissed [__] were you
where is that the [__] Blue Room you
[__] ice me for the Blue Room yeah
the blue
we just went shout out to the Blue Room
we just went oh dude this has been a
great episode man thank you for doing
this I love you man I love you as well
and uh I'm going to ask you what I ask
everybody when it's their first time on
now that we've talked about what we've
talked about advice you would give to
16-year-old H Foley the your vers you
version of H Foley uh I always this is a
little bit of off thing but I always I I
torture Kevin with this I always say if
I could go back in time you know what I
mean I always use old movies if I could
somehow get into the screen of Planes
Trains and Automobiles I could go back
and I could warn everybody I could tell
my uncle about his liver I could tell my
Dad what's going to happen they could
you know whatever
um but
I have think to myself I would go back
and [__] change everything that I did
you know what I mean where could I be
now if I if I would have [__] done
everything [__] right then I say to
myself that would take away everything
that I am and I really honestly like
going back to what I you know said I
wouldn't I'd always want to be a
foldy I'm glad that it worked out like
this you know what me and him you know
me and Kevin are doing together the
connection that we have uh with the with
the fans you know we're the strip down
version of ourselves and you know we're
being ourselves as as much as we
possibly as much we possibly can I
really wouldn't uh change anything
because all those [__] lumps and all
those [__] missteps and all that
stuff eventually got us here and you
know I'm I'm so grateful for it I would
tell myself to [__] be single in high
school cuz I was in a serious
relationship and you know I you know I
put a lot of pressure on myself and you
know we put a lot of pressure on
ourselves of like you know that again
that Bruce Springsteen like I love you
baby we'll be together forever so that's
the only thing I'd probably go back and
uh and change to [__] be a little bit
Chiller with that [__] all right yeah
dude thank you for doing this for real
thank you buddy um PL can promote
everything one more time please um arug
garbage.com for all the tickets for the
for the stay trashy tour um two episodes
a week on patreon anywhere you get your
podcast and then we do uh two episodes
every week on uh on patreon did I just
say that you did I did I [__] you do
two regular and two patreon four a week
do four a week damn you do guys do four
a week that's a lot yeah [__] yeah we do
the the one that we do is hard feelings
which is a separate podcast we do that
uh in the ice box in a little separate
Studio where it's just us that's the HR
just us bitching back and forth that we
used to do in my car for about 50 people
for about 2 years hell yeah yeah yeah
it's good stuff good for you guys thanks
buddy um love you brother love you yeah
as always Ryan sichler on all social
media ransler docomo tour we'll talk to
you all next
[Music]
[Applause]
week
[Music]